today's topic rex from tiktok hey
bestie you're wrong
i think it's time for another adult
pre-k lesson what do you think
all right turn your listening ears on
you catch a bubble in your mouth
good job okay here's the thing
having a preference is something like
i'm looking for a partner who likes
kayaking
or wakes up early in the morning or
loves
pizza but when your preferences exclude
an
entire group of marginalized people
that's problematic
okay that's not nice that's not a
preference if you lump all fat people in
one group together as though they are
not
very different individuals that's fat
phobic
gay people are marginalized i don't like
gay people i don't want to date a gay
people i don't mind gay people
i don't mind being friends with gay
people i'm not going to date a gay
people
i'm not and i'm just not my preference
so i'm being problematic because i don't
want to date
gay is that what it is i should say gay
trans
i should be lesbian i should date
lesbian yeah
because they're marginalized right that
makes no sense just our argument doesn't
make any sense
i'm gonna stay away from like the gay
straight stuff but
why not because i think orientation is
different
you know but that's me i'm going on what
she said
if your preferences excludes
a marginalized group you're being
problematic that's what she said
she included that so i'm just gonna go
with marginalized group
that's it so i'm i'm not gonna i'm gonna
include them because if i don't you know
i'm being problematic
just like lumping all black people in
one group and saying i don't like black
people is
i'm lumping all disabled people in one
group and saying i don't think people in
wheelchairs are hot
is ableist do you understand what i'm
saying saying you're not interested in
dating people
or saying that's not your preference
isn't ableist it's just saying that
i'm not interested in whatever that
comes with the same way some people
don't want to date poor people
that's okay poor people are marginalized
yes they are
guess what you don't want to date a poor
poor person who's on welfare
you're entitled to that that is your
right that is also preference i think
here's what happens right would someone
encounter something that they feel like
is not nice or it hurts them
they immediately jump to the idea of
like this is somehow evil it's like no
you know sometimes the truth is not
pretty but it doesn't mean that there is
some kind of
oppression going on or that this is
somehow some indication of some larger
systemic issue it just means that like
yeah
somebody was not interested in you our
attractions are driven by a lot of stuff
that we can't control
i get that you you can feel like it's
it's offending like
you're trying to say something like you
try to put them aside or whatever it's
just not your thing
i feel like they who you want to date
if you want to ask yourself you're the
question of why you don't like such and
such
things that's on you and you should do
that you don't like
you don't want to date black people you
don't want to be white people sure
you could ask yourself why but it
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
racist or this or that
okay i'm gonna say this already her
putting fatness on an equivalency of of
blackness is crazy
your obesity generally reflects your
day-to-day choices your lived experience
your dietary choices so for me i can
infer much more about your character
and your personality just looking at you
physically than i can a black person per
se
right i can't look at a disabled person
and be like man the reason why they're
like that is like you can't figure that
out
but if you're generally morbidly obese
yeah i'm gonna look at that and be like
that's probably not something i want in
my life now i'm not a big fan of that
people are like well trans this is like
blackness it's not
it's his own separate thing it's his own
separate thing two
if someone didn't want to date black
people i would not say this
someone didn't want to date white people
i would not say this
sometimes physically speaking you like
certain things
you're not attracted to it that's it
right
along certain races certain physical
qualities become more prevalent
okay or is it relevant i don't remember
prevalent you're the one with the words
remember i can't read oh oh people
always get on me on that word prelims
attraction is such a complicated thing
it is complex it's not
it's not easy enough to just be like
well because you have this preference
therefore you know some people just want
to date ethiopians if they may be from
ethiopia right
they want to keep that cultural heritage
some people prefer people with larger
lips
and bigger butts well you know maybe
they're going to find predominantly that
exists with black folks some people like
fair complexions and very straight hair
who knows
we are attracted to things on a complex
range of reasons
and to look at someone who's not open to
certain things and inherently say
something's wrong with you seems odd to
me smoking there's plenty of people who
don't want to date smokers yeah
they suffer from lung cancer and all
kinds of issues and the breath smells
is that wrong for me to say i don't want
to date a smoker and red heads
same thing with red right so and they've
been mars in life i mean in my school it
was
if someone doesn't want to date you why
would you want to try to impose that on
them
do you and move on that's it you could
be the sweetest ripest tastiest
mango in the world there's people that
don't like mango okay
there's gonna be someone for you like
this that's it just go
find yours don't concentrate on the
people that don't like you sponsoring
other people that
actually do there's people that
attraction is very complicated as a
matter of fact the biggest
sexual organ is the brain it's complex
so just going like that and be like no
you should like this and that
and if you're fat fool me you mean
problematic
i disagree with that they're not saying
that you guys are not ugly or fat people
are not ugly or disciplined
no it's just not their thing and you
know what
it's okay there was a time when i was
like oh yeah you don't want to date
black people what
and then you start to listen to what
you're saying you're like ah
doesn't necessarily make sense and it's
okay i'm not gonna concentrate on you
you can ask yourself why
that's another topic but it does not
inherently racist or fat phobic but
whatever do you but on that point yeah i
do disagree as well
yeah i think in a world where so many
people are valuing the idea of fitness
and staying in shape and they're trying
to change their
life habits looking at somebody who's
morbidly obese and they're like yeah
no not enough for me i wouldn't want to
date someone that is super in shape
either either like that goes to the gym
every day and everything and stuff
and it's super big because to me that's
another kind of unhealthiness yeah
people marginalize skinny people all the
time all the time
eat a sandwich oh my god look at her if
some girl's dressing super posh
right right she got a long cigarette in
all her photos and doing some weird i'm
probably like nah
some girl it's me that's me right
because
i feel like even the way that you dress
is a reflection of some of your ideas
not always but sometimes
what
what you're going to say but you dress
you judge other people and while they
dress in regards to whether or not we'd
be compatible
not in regards to who they are you don't
always don't cause you always say that
you
dress like a homeless person yeah yeah
yeah but who's gonna be compatible with
you
well i only dress like this when i'm
here in this kind of situation
it's a very different thing you've seen
me on dates with girls before i've seen
you on dates yeah more time you saw me
like oh [ __ ] thank you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah good thing when
i'm doing these videos oh yeah you put
out your good shoes and you think
something
when i'm doing these videos i'm not
trying to have them sliding whoa i
haven't looked so cute
i'm not trying to deal with you trying
to be crummy and people trying to slide
exactly
right so that's a different thing yeah
you know if you groom yourself are you
trying to make yourself beautiful
then people will be like oh well i'm not
having that so
it's a different thing but if i had an
online dating profile do you think i'm
i'm rocking the same stuff
right so i've seen it i've seen you on
my profile pics exactly so it's
it's a different thing but anyways this
man was trying to come from my neck
being like
who are you gonna be like like i'm
trying to be compatible with this camera
what i'm trying to say
listen you're judging [ __ ] and
you're always in a teacher it's not
trash but i see what you're saying
your point it makes it valuable yeah
keep it going yeah yeah as bacon grits
yeah sausage my man came for my neck
like that that's crazy
i can't bring gold you know what you're
good side no every girl i know know what
their good side is
none of my god friends know what they're
good at like this
straight up the camera you get both
sides if it's trash it's fresh
i don't even but i won't be like i'm not
doing all that
try to hide your [ __ ] yeah man try to
catch a light yeah [ __ ] am i america's
next best
yeah to me it's such a such a weird
claim it's like
you're not gonna date fan people you're
my what like i said spend less time
worrying about this kind of stuff and
more time on self-improvement
i think everyone's entitled to what they
want and you're also entitled to
discriminate against people
in terms of dating for whatever reason
you want maybe it's born from a bad
place maybe it's born from a good place
but being too invested in why other
people
want to make the choices that they want
to make seems odd to me just go spend
your time with people who want to be
with you at the end of the day that's
the only thing that matters
if i meet a girl she's like i only date
black guys i might be like where's that
coming from actually y'all can dance
really well i might be like
another black guy might be like that's
my jam
one two three five six seven one two you
never know everyone's gonna react to
these kinds of things differently and
we're all entitled to those choices
without being told
that we're somehow participating in some
kind of oppressive regime so
those are mine what do you guys think do
you guys agree on the obesity and
you know choice or not i think that's a
good discussion do you guys agree
with what she said about fat phobia and
all that stuff we want to hear from
y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
is